[Music]
a california man in custody after police
say he went on a crime spree which left
two people dead
our i-team has learned the suspect has a
very lengthy criminal history vanessa
murphy live in studio with more
on what vanessa found brian sources tell
me
29 year old john carrillo has a lengthy
criminal history mainly in california
the santa clara district attorney's
office confirms he was
just released from prison in april he
was convicted of assault with force
likely to cause great bodily
injury now police say he's responsible
for a violent crime spree in southern
nevada
including domestic batteries carjackings
robberies and
three shootings in less than a week on
wednesday in the first shooting metro
police say he shot a customer at a
convenience store
near charleston and maryland the victim
survived
on thursday a shooting at oakey and
eastern turned deadly
metro police say carrillo showed up at a
home for a drug deal
shot the victim and took his car and
then
last night just before midnight near
maryland and pyle
henderson police say carrillo shot a
32-year-old man
in the face he died and sources are
telling me this appears to be a random
act of violence
carrillo was taken into custody shortly
after
he's now accused of killing two people
shooting another who survived
and he will face a long list of charges
for again
this alleged crime spree carrillo is now
at the clark county detention center
the i-team has been digging into his
past today we'll share more
once we confirm new information